all right let's jump uh jump right into
this topic it's a big topic uh it's a
complicated one over the last several
weeks i've gotten a ton of emails from
you guys uh calls
with people asking or suggesting uh
maybe if you are unvaccinated and you
get very sick with covet and you go to
the hospital you should be refused
treatment um and of course that's not
going to happen in any real way there
are uh primary care doctors that are
saying our practice will only treat
we'll only have on our roster vaccinated
patients but if you go to an emergency
room you are not going to be denied
treatment because you are unvaccinated
for better or worth worse ethical
unethical it that's just not going to
happen but there are now
new questions it's a much more narrow
discussion and the discussion is whether
it would be fair to treat vaccinated
coveted patients first and this is more
of a triage conversation so really it's
a question of whether vaccination status
should or could be considered in terms
of triage and there's some pretty good
arguments to suggest that it should
uh which we are going to get into uh
interesting wired article which asks
would it be fair to treat vaccinated
coveted patients first
last week texas healthcare policymakers
discussed taking vaccination status into
account for covetrt triage it's a larger
conversation ethicists are bracing for
um
it's no accident that people describe
something that's calculated cold and
unemotional as clinical taking care of
people's health isn't it health isn't
emotion free by any means
but the clinic is where physicians and
nurses have to make life and death
decisions under time pressure including
which patients go first and what kind of
care they get when resources like say
ventilators or intensive care beds
oxygen staff and time or scarce
that decision making is called triage
and last week the dallas morning news
reported
that some texas hospitals were
considering a massive change to how they
do it the question in play
would it make sense to take into account
the vaccination status of their covet
patients with icus filling up with
severely ill coveted patients and a
shortage of beds and nurses should
clinicians all other things being equal
that's an important part of it
care for vaccinated people before or
differently than unvaccinated ones and
the article goes on to say it hasn't
happened and probably won't the idea
came from a memo
this is this is a very complicated
question
fundamentally this is not about ignoring
the hippocratic oath and saying don't
treat unvaccinated patients
uh they haven't taken care of themselves
assuming there's no real medical reason
why they are unvaccinated
we're going to ignore these people that
that's not what this is about
this is about
including vaccination status as part of
triage
where someone may end up getting less
care or might end up getting no care
depending on how full an emergency room
is in a moment i'll tell you about three
emergency rooms that are so full they've
closed
um and whether
the vaccination status affects chance of
recovery uh and you could on this basis
say all right you've got
a 65 year old
vaccinated patient
and a 60 year old unvaccinated patient
and if you don't consider vaccination
status you might just go by how severe
are their symptoms
their age etc if you consider
vaccination status you would have this
statistical framework in which you know
that hospitalized vaccinated patients
are more likely to survive than
unvaccinated patients that would be a
way to empirically
not in some kind of moralistic
punishment way but empirically consider
vaccination status in triage is a
vaccinated 50 year old more likely to
recover
than an unvaccinated
40 year old and there's even another
aspect of this which is if you have a
patient in the er or in the icu or
potentially going into the icu
and they're unvaccinated and they're
unvaccinated for no other reason other
than they fell for conspiracy theories
does it stand to reason that they may
generally be less likely to heed the
advice that they are given in that
hospital if granted an intensive care
unit would it be fair to consider that
as well and of course there's there's
the important inclusion of the idea all
else being equal and really the the i
think the gist here
is not to make
unclear triage calls about a vaccinated
55 year old and an unvaccinated 40 year
old but really more about situations
where it's
almost identical situations you might
have two people
equally sick
same age
one vaccinated one unvaccinated and you
have one spot in the icu would it be
fair to say we're going to take the
vaccinated patient because statistically
they're more likely to recover and in
general they are probably more likely to
heed our advice this is not
unheard of
elsewhere
uh on the basis of a a different sort of
sort of health considerations alcoholics
historically
have been considered unsuitable for
liver transplants because of the
presumed high risk of relapsing to
excessive drinking which could ruin the
transplanted liver that's that's a
lifestyle choice that is factored into
organ donation although there are people
who rightly say well it's not really a
lifestyle choice alcoholism is a disease
and then it becomes more complex but the
point is that it is it's similar it's
analogous to some degree triage is about
chances of survival but it's also about
available resources it's also about
patient willingness to comply with
medical advice and people who are
vaccinated are not only more likely to
survive they've shown a motivation
to follow the widely accepted medical
advice and ultimately this is about
available resources and we've talked
before and i'm going to give you an
example in the next story of this
when you have a full icu
with disproportionately unvaccinated
people not because of a medical
condition that says don't get vaccinated
but because they've chosen not to get
vaccinated if you get into a car
accident if you have a heart attack if
you have a work injury
and you're vaccinated and you go in for
something serious not related to covid
you may not be able to get the treatment
you need because of people who have
simply chosen not to get vaccinated and
so there is an element of this which is
that people who are not looking out for
society are consuming resources and
hurting other people people who maybe
would survive after that car crash if
they could get right into an icu but the
icu is full because of unvaccinated
people so i think it's completely
reasonable to take it into account in
triage i'm not saying you don't provide
treatment
but the question about triage
considerations seems completely logical
to me
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com slash pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before it's a lifesaver and here's how
it works takes just a couple of minutes
to set up anytime you buy something
online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them you can delete them
anytime you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman